[Música]
[Aplausos]
yo crecí en las chinampas de míxquic
recuerdo perfectamente que amaba
observar a los animales en mi jardín
oler la tierra mojada y aunque no me
gustan las serpientes las observaba
desde lejos habían unos animalitos que
me fascinaban porque volaban muy rápido
tenían los colores metálicos otros serán
más discretos y cuando lograba atrapar a
los que eran inofensivos caminaban sobre
mi mano adivinaste que animales son los
insectos como las catarinas las
mariposas las libélulas las avispas las
moscas
durante mi niñez yo crecí con ellos y
aunque algunas veces demasiado muy
molestos por ejemplo a quien no le ha
pasado que no puede dormir porque hay un
insecto en nuestra recámara
o esa mosca que anda chocando todo el
tiempo con los otros a pesar de eso me
seguían gustando
quiero contarte una historia que cambió
completamente mi vida cuando yo era niña
un día mis padres me dijeron cierra la
ventana de tu cuarto y no salgas de la
casa yo les pregunté qué pasa ellos me
dijeron que habían granjeros aplicando
insecticidas para matar insectos y otros
bichos que estaban en los cultivos
eso de cerrar la ventana y no salir de
mi cuarto se repetía cada año y me
molestaba mucho ahora que pienso de
niños tenemos una gran curiosidad por
todo y la porque matan a los
insectos sabía que mataban a los
insectos que eran nocivos pero también a
los benéficos como las catarinas inhibe
lula
y si los insecticidas pueden matar a los
insectos pueden ocasionar enfermedades a
la gente que consume brócoli esta
curiosidad
y asombro por los insectos más mi
interés por el bienestar de la gente me
llevó a estudiar biología en la unam y
especializarme en entomología sabes que
es la entomología es la ciencia que
estudia los insectos
siempre he considerado que ser un
entomólogo es como tratar de llegar al
fondo del mar porque nunca dejarás de
aprender y siempre encontrarás nuevos
insectos
hice mi investigación sobre unos
insectos muy raros que ayudan a producir
frutas y verduras estos son las
catarinas peludas
durante este estudio encontramos que las
catarinas peludas tienen un alto
potencial para comer insectos y bichos
nocivos que se alimentan de las frutas y
verduras que nosotros consumimos
además ayudará a producir frutas y
verduras libres de químicos que dañan
nuestra salud
al terminar este estudio me quedé con
muchas ganas de seguir investigando los
beneficios de los insectos en la gente y
la naturaleza
este fue el inicio de una aventura que
hice en colombia en un laboratorio de la
universidad del tolima alimente y cuide
a unas avispas muy pequeñas que comen
moscas de la fruta que atacan a los
cultivos del mango
te preguntarás por qué alimentar y
cuidar a unas avispas en un laboratorio
porque queríamos saber todo acerca de
ellas desde cuánto tiempo viven cuántas
moscas se comen cuántas avispas nacen
cuántas mueren toda esta información y
en un mismo propósito que es eliminar
esas moscas que se dañan a los mangos
a mi regreso de colombia quería saber
sobre temas ambientales así que decidí
hacer una maestría en la universidad de
wageningen en los países bajos mi
creatividad y curiosidad me llevó a
investigar los beneficios de los
insectos en zonas agrícolas y naturales
para mi sorpresa los insectos ayudan a
la gente y la naturaleza en tres
aspectos importantes
uno ayudan a combatir plagas de insectos
y otros bichos y malezas como las
plantas
quiero que te imagines a una catarina
roja con manchas negras está volando
hacia un árbol de limón se para en una
hoja donde encuentra unos deliciosos
áfidos que son insectos nocivos para el
árbol de limón
sabes cuántos áfidos puede comer una
catarina al día hasta ahora se sabe que
una catarina al día puede comer hasta
500 áfidos ahora imagínate que la
catarina sólo encuentra 10 áfidos es
decir se queda con mucha hambre así que
busca quiere buscar más comida y para su
sorpresa en ese mismo árbol encuentra
muchísimos áfidos
alberto alta comida está catalina decide
quedarse y formar una familia así sus
hijos tendrán alimento durante ese
tiempo más caterina llegan a comer de
los áfidos los áfidos se terminan y las
catarinas deciden a otro lugar
a todo este proceso se le conoce como
control biológico y el beneficio es que
ese árbol de limón vivirá más tiempo
para producir limones y así tú te podrás
hacer una rica agua de limón
el segundo beneficio es que los insectos
ayudan a producir verduras frutas y
semillas por medio de la polinización
en esta historia quiero que te imagines
a un abejorro muy peluditos con líneas
amarillas y negras está zumbando y
volando hacia la flor de un manzano
llega a la flor del manzano se alimentan
de néctar y por estar moviéndose se
llena de polen de repente ya no hay
néctar así que decide buscar otra flor
llega a la flor del manzano comer el
néctar y el polen que tiene en su cuerpo
se queda en una estructura de la flor
que necesita del polen para producir una
manzana grande y deliciosa
el último beneficio es que los insectos
ayudan a degradar materia orgánica
para esta historia la actriz principal
es una mosca embarazada que está volando
cerca del bosque donde encuentra una
guayaba fermentada pero para ella es
deliciosa empieza a comerse la guayaba y
considera que a sus futuros hijos les
gustará ese alimento así que decide
poner unos 300 huevecillos de esos
jueves y yo os haré unas pequeñas larvas
blancas que inmediatamente se comen los
restos de la guayaba se termina el
alimento y se van a otro lugar en
búsqueda de más comida fermentada
de todas estas historias que te conté te
das cuenta que los insectos ayudan a
nuestro planeta y a la gente
cada insecto tiene un propósito ya sea
que ayuda a controlar plagas ayuda a
producir verduras frutas y semillas por
medio de la polinización o degrade
materia orgánica
además durante mis estudios conocí
diversas instituciones que hacen
reportes ambientales y uno de ellos es
la evaluación mundial sobre la
biodiversidad biológica y los servicios
de los ecosistemas
en este informe mencionan que nuestro
planeta está cambiando muy rápido debido
a las acciones humanas principalmente
estamos cambiando el uso de tierra y mar
explotando los animales y otros
organismos cambiando el clima
contaminado y están apareciendo nuevas
especies invasoras
y te preguntarás qué está pasando con
los insectos
varios entomólogos y científicos
ambientales como danés verde henson y
chris wyse hop y francisco sánchez bayo
mencionan en sus publicaciones que los
insectos se encuentran bajo amenaza en
todo el planeta de todas las de todos
los animales que habitan en nuestro
planeta que son terrestres dos terceras
partes son insectos y de este total el
40% de los insectos desaparecerá en las
próximas décadas la pérdida de los
insectos es un evento muy alarmante
porque sus beneficios del mineral es
decir será más difícil consumir miel
manzanas almendras limones jitomates y
otros productos que nosotros nos
alimentamos además será más difícil
controlar plagas y degradar materia
orgánica por medio de los insectos
y ahora te preguntarás a qué se debe la
pérdida de los insectos la pérdida de
los insectos se debe principalmente
también a las actividades humanas
por ejemplo capturar insectos para
ponerlos en cuadros calor de nuestra
casa matar a los insectos sin saber si
son benéficos o nocivos
quitar árboles plantas pastos nativos e
incluso objetos naturales como rocas y
piedras ocasiona que los insectos no
tengan un lugar para descansar y
alimentarse
utilizar fertilizantes y químicos
sintéticos para producir más comida el
cambio climático está afectando a los
insectos principalmente a los que se
encuentran en zonas tropicales y del
mediterráneo
al investigar los efectos del cambio
climático en los insectos que ayudan a
controlar plagas y polinizar a los
almendros en el mediterráneo español
encontré que los insectos no podrán
tolerar altas y bajas temperaturas
fríos y lluvias lluvias muy intensos en
esta historia que te voy a contar
hay una
abeja muy trabajadora
poliniza a las flores de los almendros
esta abeja tiene una jornada de trabajo
de 10 de la mañana a 6 de la tarde es
decir trabajo 8 horas como muchas de las
personas ahora quiero que te imagines
que tú eres es abeja crees que podrás
recolectar néctar
durante 8 horas bajo el sol
crees que podrás volar con mucho viento
o mucha lluvia
yo creo que no porque en días muy
calurosos tus alas se calientan en días
con mucho viento no podrás volar en días
con mucho frío te congelas en días con
mucha lluvia es posible que no salgas de
tu panal o incluso en el peor de los
casos tu panal se inunde
para evitar la pérdida de los insectos
que debes de hacer que comparto cinco
ideas uno siembra múltiples flores en tu
jardín así los insectos tendrán polen y
néctar para alimentarse 2
evita quitar el pasto y si es posible
dejarlo crecer 3 amontonar rocas y
madera para que traigan los insectos
4 conservar es natural es evitar tirar
basura y trata de no pisar y o cortar
pasto y plantas 5
cuida el agua de las de los canales
charcas e incluso de las fuentes de tu
comunidad porque los insectos utilizan
este espacio para refrescarte ellos
también merecen tener un agua limpia
para bañarse y hidratarse
y cultivar frutas y verduras y quieres
ayudar a los insectos de con tanto 5
ideas 1 no utilices químicos sintéticos
como los insecticidas y herbicidas opta
por productos orgánicos
2 evita el uso excesivo de fertilizantes
mejor utiliza cubiertas vegetales así te
ayudarán a regresar nutrientes al suelo
o productos orgánicos
deja entre y alrededor de tu parcela
áreas verdes es decir no quites por
completo las plantas y pastos nativos y
si es posible amontona rocas y madera
así atraerás en los insectos
4 no siempre solo un cultivo en tu
parcela opta por diversos frutas y
verduras así los insectos te ayudarán a
polinizar tus frutas y verduras y si
fueran el caso de que tengan plagas
también te ayudarán a controlar las 5
si tienes muchos insectos nocivos en tu
cultivo opta por
consultar a un experto en cultivos
orgánicos oa un entomólogo espías
especializado en control de plagas
agrícolas
un día el biólogo y entomólogo edward
jones ball wilson dijo si toda la
humanidad desapareciera el planeta se
regeneraría de nuevo al mismo estado de
equilibrio que existía hace diez mil
años
si los insectos desaparecen el medio
ambiente se derrumbaría en el caos y tú
piensas conservar a los insectos
[Música]
[Aplausos]